-Welcome back!
I'm about to play
a brand-new game called
Golf Pong,
which is why I'm
standing on AstroTurf
facing six giant cups of beer.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Now, I'm gonna need a competitor
worthy of the Golf Pong course.
So, ladies and gentlemen,
please welcome, the one and only
Michael Strahan!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-What's up, what's up,
what's up? Hello, everybody!
-That's what I'm talking about!
-What's up, fellas?
-Uh, alright, here's how the
game works.
We're going take turns trying to
hit golf balls
into those giant red cups.
If you make a shot, your
opponent has to chug a beer.
First one
to make three shots wins.
Michael, you're my guest,
so, uh, you can go first.
-Oh, you don't want? Okay,
let's see what we got here.
-See I'm a little worried
because I think...
-Whoa!
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Ha!
-Ooh.
-Ha-ha!
On the first shot?
First shot, ready?
-I'm sorry. Okay go ahead
knock yourself let's go.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Will I drink or won't I drink?
-[ Laughs ]
-That is the question.
-You're going to have to.
Alright. Here we go.
-You're gonna practice swing
on a game?
-Well, I mean I have a, I have
a, I have a back lower back.
[ Laughter ]
[ Gasps ]
[ Cymbal clashes ]
Too much.
-A little too much.
-Working out
a little bit too much, yeah.
-Words you never heard before,
a little too much.
-Oh. Wow, unbelievable.
Unbelievable. Unbelievable.
-Whoo!
-Oh!
-Oh, Jimmy!
-I told you this!
I told the producers,
they said
"Dude, it's gonna take
a long time,"
I go, "No, you've never seen
Strahan, he's awesome.
-Come on, you got this, man.
-I know I --
-I wanna drink!
I wanna drink something.
-I know, I know.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Mm. It's like beer
mixed with White Claw.
-You can do it.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Alright, bud here we go.
-Come on, man, you got it.
[ Audience whoops ]
[ Audience groans ]
Just give me one more.
-I'll give you one more.
[ Laughter ]
-Alright. Here we go.
-You can do it!
-Alright. Yeah, Jimmy!
[ Audience whoops ]
[ Audience groans ]
-[ Sighs ] Ah, God.
[ Exhales sharply ]
Is it, are you gonna just win
right here? This is it.
You just crushed me
in this, man.
-Um...
-Like last time we played,
and you sank that putt.
Oh, my God come on not the...
It's not gonna happen.
-Aw!
-If that went in.
-If I would've made that.
-If that went in
that would've been,
I would've had to retire.
What, what am I?
-[ Laughs ]
-Oh, my God don't laugh.
When you laugh like that I know
that means you're gonna win.
Hold, on.
-Go ahead, man.
You can, I want --
make me drink once.
-Alright.
This one, here we go, you ready?
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Oh, get it up!
-[ Blows raspberry ]
[ Audience groans ]
-God!
Put too much power.
There's too much power.
-You need more finesse.
-Maybe I gotta
move my grass back.
-Yeah, like, finesse,
you gotta finesse.
-Oh, it's my finesse game.
-Alright. Here we go.
-You crushed me in this,
come on.
-Too much, oh!
[ Audience groans ]
-Alright, so too much.
Here we go.
I'm gonna "Happy Gilmore"
into it.
[ Light laughter ]
No, that was what I did there.
-How'd that work out for you?
-No it didn't work out.
Alright.
-Alright. Here we go.
Last.
-Darn!
-Last one here.
-Yes. Good. I love that
that's it.
That's, that's all I needed.
To motivate me, here we go.
[ Cheers and applause ]
[ Scoffs ] My God.
-Can I just drink it,
because I want to?
-[ Laughs ] Yes, yes you can.
See, that's what
I'm talking about!
That's what I'm --
that ball came back to me.
-Yeah, that's alright,
here we go. Good, good, good.
Alright. Maybe if I put the ball
further back here,
in the fake grass.
-I love. I --
You have all these theories as
to what's wrong.
[ Light laughter ]
-Oh!
-My ball keeps coming back to me
do I get points for that?
[ Laughter ]
-Alright, Jimmy. Here we go.
-Alright. This is it.
Gosh darn it. N--
Oh, my gosh!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Not my day!
Not my day! Come on!
-There you go, friend.
-Cheers. Come on.
-Cheers.
-That's what I'm talking about,
Michael Strahan.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Michael Strahan, everybody!
Business clothing line MSX by
Michael Strahan
is available now
at Men's Warehouse
and Moores nationwide and online
at msxbymichaelstrahan.com.
We're chatting more with Michael
after the break, stick around.
-♪ Uh-huh,
call it Captain Rock ♪
♪ Started at the bottom,
now I'm lonely at the top, yo ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]